kurze pause beim homeschooling bei
familie soll seit vier wochen lassen die
eltern ihre kinder chloe 7 und loop5
nicht mehr in die schule es sei ein ort
ohne schutz vor omikron so die eltern
masken pflicht im land wurde abgeschafft
die regierung erlaubt bislang das impfen
von unter 12 jährigen nicht es sei also
kein wunder dass die infektionszahlen
unter den kindern seit omikron steigen
und steigen meinen dies als also packten
sie die kleinen einen zum kämpfen nach
frankreich zwei kurztrips mit dem auto
der mit der gesundheit der kinder spiele
man nicht
was mich dazu getrieben hat die kinder
impfen zu lassen war als ich erkannte
wie groß doch die zahl der ungeimpften
kinder ist die ins krankenhaus müssen
während der mikrowelle in den usa und
israel
und ich dachte
alle reden davon wie mild omikron ist
aber das stimmt so nicht
natürlich waren sie eine kleine
sensation in der französischen klinik
erzählt vater chris und es gab
anfeindungen im internet unverständnis
bei bekannten kleinkinder impfen sei
doch nicht sicher hieß es so die die
höflich waren doch millionen kämpfte
kids in aller welt die keine schweren
nebenwirkungen zeigten dass spreche doch
eine deutliche sprache
wir haben die kinder einen monat davor
gegen grippe impfen lassen warum nicht
gegen kuwait wo es doch sichere
impfstoffe gibt ich bin vor allem
besorgt wegen möglicher langfristiger
folgen des virus auswirkungen auf das
herz kreislauf system das gehirn was
passiert in fünf oder zehn jahren wir
wissen noch nicht viel über dieses lyon
stolz präsentieren luke und chloe ihre
urkunden vermutliche kinder geimpft und
damit besser geschützt lassen die eltern
die beiden auch wieder in die schule
gehen für die regierung haben dies als
nur kopfschütteln übrig ständig werde
betont so die eltern dass die schulen um
jeden preis offen gehalten werden sollen
weil der unterrichtsausfall so viel
schaden angerichtet habe auch seelisch
doch der vielleicht beste schutz gegen
korona die impfung bleibe bei den
jüngsten ungenutzt wie viel impfungen da
bringen sei noch nicht ausreichend
belegt argumentiert die regierung fakt
dagegen ist schulen sind in england der
neue omikron hotspot die zahlen steigen
gegen den allgemeinen trend fast 400.000
schüler sind anfang februar krank jeder
zwanzigste im schnitt fällt fast jeder
zehnte lehrer aus in dieser situation
der die masken pflicht abgeschafft nicht
alle schulen machen damit angesprochen
auf die schwierige situation erklärt der
wirtschaftsminister
aber wir sind noch nicht raus aber die
größten herausforderungen der pandemie
haben wir gemeistert
die regierung denkt sogar darüber nach
das masken tragen in schulen zu
verbieten auch weil immer mehr ihre
eigenen regeln machen etwa die dsl die
deutsche schule in london gerd klein
allein so war es lange in der pandemie
musikunterricht in corona zeiten oft ein
totalausfall zu gefährlich seit sommer
wird wieder durchgehend musiziert auch
in der haakon bälle
sowie einer deutschen schule ist es
aufgrund der maßnahmen die glaube ich
ein wenig strenger sind als im rest des
landes haben wir auch es ist geringere
fallzahlen habe ich das gefühl es geht
so von anderen schulen mit dass es da
teilweise sehr hoch ist und ich glaube
das hält sich hier noch sehr im rahmen
vielleicht auch aufgrund der maske und
belüftungssystem
etwas aus dem takt geraten sind sie man
merke schon dass viel unterricht
ausgefallen ist erklärt lehrer klein
aber langsam läuft es wieder rund
dass die regierung ausgerechnet jetzt
das ende aller einschränkungen in
schulen einläutet hält er für verfrüht
allein schon weil in den letzten wochen
jeder fünfte lehrer an der dsl corona
bedingt zu hause bleiben musste
das hat noch keiner aber in
unmittelbarer nähe hat ja einige corona
fälle gegeben und die inzidenz in die
jetzt gerade unter den kleinen hoch hoch
schießen dann hat man im prinzip ist ja
dann ist die schule der ort wo eine
höhere instanz ist als außerhalb
nach den weihnachtsferien ein corona
test die masken pflicht bleibt und
kleine maßnahmen die niemandem wehtun
aber die sicherheit erhöhen sollen auch
wenn es manchmal nervt erzählt die
17-jährige leer aber alles was helfe
dass die schule offen bleibt und sie
nicht krank wird das sei doch eine
selbstverständlichkeit sie fühlt sich
sicherer mit maske
ich hab nicht um den gangs cola zu
bekommen so vor der krankheit an sich
habe er angst davor zu hause zu bleiben
von der woche schule zu verpassen selbst
wenn man dann mit dem colin wir ein
gerufen wird man versteht einfach nicht
hier so akustisch gesehen inhaltlich
gesehen gerade im abitur das
funktioniert nicht so
leas klassenkamerad benedikt ist
kritischer die jüngeren die schüler
hätten in der pandemie so viel opfer
bringen müssen und die maske schütze
doch kaum jedenfalls was ihn und seine
mitschüler betrifft ich freue mich bei
kallwass gewarnt sein müssen unterricht
im öffentlich verkehrsmittel werde ich
auch nächsten paar jahren noch in moskau
anziehen aber
munter richtig sitzt
war mehr sportunterricht im sportmagazin
geht schlecht das heißt wir vermischen
sonst und auch wenn wir uns außerhalb
der schule treffen die maske schränkt
ein machte aber auch dinge möglich wie
beim besuch des kinderbuch illustrators
axel scheffler bei den grundschülern
ohne eine gewisse vorsicht sind solche
events noch nicht möglich
ich habe ja noch nicht so viele
veranstaltungen jetzt wieder gemacht
aber natürlich hat man den gedanken ist
man sicher und sind die kinder sicher
und in diesem falle war ich eigentlich
hatte ich das vertrauen dass das ist
eigentlich eine sichere situation ist
dass man genug abstand hatte ich würde
wahrscheinlich nicht um ein kleines
klassenzimmer gehen das nicht gelüftet
ist sondern also die bedingungen spielen
schon eine rolle alle wollen zurück zur
normalität so wie es vor der pandemie
war nur über das tempo herrscht
uneinigkeit boris johnson hat jetzt
angekündigt dass infizierte sich wohl
schon ende februar nicht mehr isolieren
müssen das ist für die deutsche schule
in london zu schnell so viel vertrauen
dass omikron das ende der pandemie
einläutet haben sie hier noch nicht
[Musik]